[Music]
hey guys let's talk about chest hair
what do you think should men shave their
chest there give me your honest opinion
in the comment section down below you
know i'm starting to realize just how
important dna is because as i'm slowly
getting older i'm starting to lose hair
here on top and so i started to use i
restore and even look into other hair
growth treatments as well but now
it looks like these hairs are starting
to grow in other places like a hair or
two on my shoulders and even on my chest
i'm making jokes but honestly i don't
like it i don't like it to see hairs on
my shoulder slowly coming out and i've
never seen them there before but it is
what it is it's in our dna and some of
you are going through this with me
you're slowly getting more hair on your
shoulders
your back
your chest
and your nose and other places
but now in this video we're talking
about chest air and the question is
should men shave their chest hair or
should you just let it grow because it
looks more manly i actually asked a lot
of you on my community page
now 20 of you said no leave it it looks
more manly and 19
said yes your chest will look better
without it and smell better and 61 said
maybe it depends on how much hair you
have
all right now that's interesting let me
give you my honest opinion i actually
like my chest here you know but that
being said i will shave it
when it becomes too much if it becomes
too much i mean i don't want my hair my
body to look like the amazon
some guys they look like the kalahari
desert they have no chest hair and that
is also fine because it's who you are
it's your dna now listen to me very
carefully
it's actually smarter to ask this
question to the woman in your life ask
her what she likes leave it
grow it
trim it
shave it
ask her if you do this for her she'll
probably do similar things for you as
well now if you do want to shave it off
because of her or because you do
something else like bodybuilding then
don't shave it off just wax it that is
if you can take the pain
another good option is depilatory cream
that's for men is a good option and of
course i'll add a few more good options
for you in the video description down
below
now talking about chest hair what about
your legs should men shave their legs
well if you want to know the answer
check out this video here and i'll see
you there and before you go always
remember life is short so don't waste
yours cheers guys